>> CROSBY: So, I'm Scott Crosby at Rice University.
This is my research into rendering my post
doc on Google Wave--on a security. So I decided
to look at the authentication the Google Wave
is--Google Wave uses for its cryptography.
So, crypto Google--so Google Wave uses a lot
of crypto and the generally--generally speaking,
three of the major goals of cryptography are
authentication. If you get who created that
kind of message. The second goal of cryptography
is integrity, dealing with defective messages
are corrupted or altered. The third reason
for...
>> Louder.
>> CROSBY: Oh, the third reason for cryptography
is confidentiality. And I did a benchmark
for--based on the FedOne text clients. We
just basically inserted blips into Waves continuously
and I got about--and I--in that benchmark
showed that it was spending about 80% of their
time was spent on cryptography, in particular,
RSA signing and that's because RSA signing
is about 10 milliseconds a signature. So there's
a few solutions for this problem, one is you
could consider using DSA. DSA signatures are
about 10 times faster. You can also consider
hash tree based designs which can offer throughputs
much, much higher. And for verifying, of course,
it's a tradeoff; faster signing, slower verification;
slower signing, faster verification. RSA can
verify about 3,500 messages per second and
I'm going to--it is my research topic called
"The Spliced Signatures." So in this talk,
I'm going to focus on reducing the crypto
costs by both appropriate choice of cryptography
primitives and also aspect of the system design.
And the goal is to create a primitive that's
semantically identical to sign each message
one at a time individually. I don't want to
add any new interesting semantics, a design.
So why is OpenSSL not a good solution for
this? It's fast, well-implemented and widespread,
and OpenSSL is also very cheap. Once you initiate
a session, you're just paying basically cryptographic
hash costs as--cryptographic hash costs and
encryption costs which have extremely high
throughputs and of course, framing overheads.
An OpenSSL is good and is using Google Wave
but offers primarily confidentiality; no one
can read the XMPP communication. It also offers
integrity; you can detect it if it gets corrected
and, of course, SSL serves--also serve extremely
valuable purpose. They bind a public key to
a domain name so you can tell who is the actual
public key for wave.google.com. So when the
prompts OpenSSL is it doesn't really give
authentication in a useful fashion--in a system
like--federated system like Google Wave because
the sender of a message, the source of a message
isn't actually the author of the message.
For example, if I'm the author of a message
or an update that's gets in the home--remote
home or remote serve--home server for some
Wave then gets redistributed to a client,
those clients receive the message from the
home server, not me. So, therefore--and you
want to prevent corrupt, broken, or otherwise--a
corrupt, broken, or rooted home server from
forging messages under my identity. And other
issues are, for example, that OpenSSL only
authenticates the end point of the communication,
which means it can't actually cache the information.
You can't usefully cache the signature along
with the actual messaging question. And two,
so therefore, Wave on authenticating messages
for signing, there's a lot--tons of signatures.
Roughly each wavelet operation has to be signed
when it gets sent. And for verifying, nominally,
each reader has to verify each wavelet op,
so if a wave has 10 readers in different servers;
that could potentially mean 10 verifications
for each operation. So, therefore, verifying
is at least as frequent as signing and possibly
much more frequent. And crypto is slow. Here
are some benchmarks taken on Java using one
CPU core of a Core i7 machine in terms of
the rate per second. Now FedOne, if you disable
a cryptography, gets about 300 messages per
CPU second. But using the current RSA 2048-bit
signatures, performance is a lot lower, I
believe, around 80 or so per second and this
is why 80% of the time is spent on the crypto.
Now the first optimization you could consider
is well-known Merkle trees from about 30 years
ago. Now you use to amortize one expensive
signature over as many messages. And in this
case, I use SHA-256 hash operations, they're
a bottom--I need about 10 to 20 of them about
a microsecond each to do this. So a Merkle
tree is--starts off the use all the messages
in the leaves of a tree. Here's an example
of seven messages. Then, you then create internal
nodes in a tree where the hash--the hash of
an interior node is the hash link it initially--hashes
of its children. So the first one on the left
is the hash of the concatenation of the hashes
of the messages X1 and X2 and so forth and
of course, you can add additional layers up
to the tree creating a root. If you take that
root, you can then proceed to sign it. Here,
the box represents the signature over the
root hash value, not the--doesn't actually--does
not actually contain a hash value. Then, of
course, this can be--this energy can authenticate
all the messages in the tree. Now if you want
to actually authenticate a specific message,
it's actually pretty cheap. You just have
to send, in this case, four separate hashes
because from these hashes, I can infer up
the tree where the root should be. Here's,
of course, the implicit parts of the tree
that are in a sense--and it can then check
is the reconstructed root hash equal to the
hash that was signed if the signature matches?
Then the dark green nodes combined with verifying
the root hash can authenticate my message
right there. You don't have to send, in this
case, four hashes or about 128 bytes. And
Merkle trees are insanely fast. So, the actual
Merkle tree itself is about 20 microseconds
a message, to act--this amortize cost of--if
you have between 10 and 100,000--10 and 10,000
messages and it costs to build the tree and
also to build and serialize the [INDISTINCT]
tree and that's from basically a list of blobs
to a list of signature blobs all serialized.
And you only serialize one tree for each leaf.
So if I have, you know, 10,000 messages; put
it on a Merkle tree or 10,000 byte arrays
put in a Merkle tree and then generate 10,000
byte arrays of serialized protocol buffers.
For each of the 10,000 distinct messages is,
in this case, about 200 milliseconds. You
never actually use a tree this big. So they
actually use this where you need asynchronous
signing API and here's an example of one such
APIs you have. An outgoing message may have
a signature call that gets called with the
byte array and of course, you can also request
for where the message byte is to be signed.
Now, I actually have a main implementation
code. I actually pass back a protocol buffer--builder
objects is--the idea is it's within my code
base that I designed to be integrated with
Google Wave. I take out the protocol buffer,
I put in appropriate fields for the Merkle
tree information. That gets called back and
then the part that has--the part that signs
each message individually using a certificate
as in--sets its own necessary fields and then,
of course, it serializes it via the normal
processing flow. And, of course, the--since
I'm not sending messages one at a time, I've
designed a batch, I have basically a sign
queue where I just submit a message to the
queue. And whenever I want to, I call the
run method which basically builds a Merkle
tree and processes everything. So actually
benchmark this on the new API using--and this
is including the public key signature, RSA
or DSA. And one CPU core can process over
30,000 messages per second potentially and
that's--and you can also choose the CPU utilization.
And the idea is that if messages arrive faster,
the trees get larger. If messages arrive slower,
the trees get smaller if you run the queue
as fast as possible and you do that--can do
that to minimize the latency. Alternatively,
if you have a latency demand that's lower,
you can run on a slower schedule. For example,
run every 10 milliseconds, in which case,
CPU usage remains approximately the same.
Sorry. If you run DSA at 10 milliseconds,
CPU usage will drop significantly and latency
will increase because cryptographic hashes
are much fast. In practice, RSA message rates
at a few thousand per second. Almost all your
time is actually spent in the RSA signatures
so you have inherent overload resistance if
messages write faster, unexpectedly fast.
The next part is for--this is how do you optimize
verification? Verifications are harder to
optimize because in practice, the user sends
consecutives message on a Wave. The--Because
of latency, they'll probably be in different
batches which means that the number of public
keys that a federate server has to verify
is roughly equal to the number of messages
that are sent on the Wave. Now, this isn't
quite true: a large scale provider, like a
Google scale provider for federation, might
happen to notice--get--receive many messages
from the same batch on the same--from the
same batch and it could receive message--sorry.
A large scale provider like Google could no--could
happen to receive messages sent to--from different
users on different Waves which happen to occur
in the same batch and not re-verify the root
public key signature multiple times. But for
a smaller scale provider, roughly the number
of public key verifies equals the number of
messages sent to that federated provider.
And what that means is unlimited to the throughput
of standard public crypto algorithms which
is 3,700 messages per second with RSA or about
5,000--sorry, 580 per second with DSA. But
you don't actually have to verify all the
messages immediately in many situations. For
example, you want to verify asynchronously.
For example, the users of a Wave--the participant--some
of their participants on a Wave may in fact
be offline in which case you could, in principle,
avoid verifying their signatures until the
user actually logs in, then you verify all
of the queued up messages that were target
to them. And the user might be, for example,
read-only. It might be just reading the Wave
without actually actively modifying it, in
which case you might be willing to accept
a few seconds of latency in return for a lower--in
return for reducing crypto overheads. And
finally, of course, if a participant is just
added to a Wave on a new federated server,
there's a catch up in all the old messages,
in which case you don't want to catch up [INDISTINCT]
version saying [INDISTINCT] every message
in the entire history since the beginning.
In some other cases, being one asynchronous
verifying API, something along these lines
right here. We have incoming message and a
couple of get the signature, get the bytes--get
the data bytes and a callback that gets called
when it gets verified. Now, when you're verifying
it, you of course consummate incoming message
saying, "Here's a message right here." And
we also want to force an incoming message.
This means basically I need to know this message
is valid right now. And--or you can also force
everything in the queue. Reason why I do this
right here is if you want to exploit delayed
messages, you need to indicate when a message
has to be verified immediately. In other words,
you want to let it sit around because as soon
as you get to an asynchronous place, signatures
can amortize one public key verification over
several messages. And there's actually--are
a lot of locality in a message for Google
Wave. So here, I collected--so here I received
from Google interarrival times for wave messages.
So here what I do is I basically look at,
for a user on a specific wave, what fraction
in the messages were sent with an arrival
time less than the threshold? So it's saying
that 55% of the messages the user sends on
the wave are less than one second from the
proceeding message on that wave. And, of course,
here the rate goes up to 98% at 20 seconds.
So if you're catching up and from--so if you're
doing a catch-up, you could somehow exploit
the asynchronous verification. It could potentially
reduce a large asynchronous verifications
by a rather large margin in many of these
scenarios. For example, a logged-off user,
when they log in, you might be able to save
98% of the signature verifications if they're
the only participant on that wave on that
server. So what a spliced signature is sort
of amortizing one public key verification
over a sequence of messages. So here, I assume
I have a stream of messages. I have the cooperation
of the signer. The signer has to explicitly
include splice points in each signature. Splices
are also transitive and this is--splice is
also transitive. I'll show you an example
on the next slide. And this is a subject of
a research paper that will be going out in
about a week and a half. So here's a use case.
Let's say Alice publishes to some wave, three
messages; A, B and C, each which includes
a splice in the proceeding message. At this
point, Bob, a user on that wave on different
federate server, logs in. At that point, he
wants to verify and catch up on all the proceeding
messages. What Bob can do is balancing and
verifying a signature on A, B, and C individually.
It could do that but it can notice that these
splices exist and can be connected together.
So Bob can--so at this point, Bob will force
the message--the message basically A and will
implicitly get--in this case, Bob can force
the message C, verify the one public key signature
on C, and then get all three messages basically
for free with one public key verification
using very cheap hash operations. There's
a lot of bookkeeping to track all the partial
dependencies of all the splices and implementation
terms. But this is--the principle of it is
it's--if you want to force a particular message,
you figure out--you do one public key verification
and you get--and you get--potentially get
one or many other messages for free with no
public key verifications at all. So the benefits
of this are--was done on a trace of 9 million
messages derived from Google Wave data. Here,
I inferred--here, I actually modeled the situation
where I actually inferred log in and log off
times for users. So if some of the user was
online, then they wanted zero latency. If
they were offline, I was allowed to queue
up messages until they became online. So this
scenery right here, roughly half the messages
were forced, meaning I'd had to have them
verified immediately. The other half, I was
able to delay verification. However, I performed
fewer RSA verifications. This is because as
many times our system was overloaded faster
than they can do RSA verifications 22% of
the time. In these cases right here, I was
unable to verify RSA messages as fast--messages
that--I was unable to verify messages that
were needed to be verified now as fast as
they were arriving. So they got buffered up
and I was able to, with one verification,
get several of these messages at once. So
even despite being overloaded 22% of the time,
I have latency less than 30 milliseconds,
99 and a half, 0.5% of them. In worst cases,
only a couple hundred milliseconds despite
being overloaded far faster; this was including
all the bookkeeping overhead as far as the
signature module goes. Now, protocol changes
to incorporate this in dif. For example, the
FedOne protocol this time. We need more forward
compatible representation of what a signed
wavelet delta is, because you need to support,
for example, individually send messages as
is now possibly in a Merkle tree approach,
or splice signatures if you decide to use
them; also possibly handle RSA or DSA signatures.
Finally, there's a new cryptographic hash
being worked on right now which will become
the future SHA-3. Just as AES was produced--the
result of the contest in about--between 2000
and 2002. There's a currently ongoing contest
to replace SHA-1 and the SHA-2 family of hash
functions. So you need it to be able to handle
the future migration to SHA-3. I have a design
and I may bring it up in the protocol discussion
later today. So basically, I looked at ways--so
here's possible solutions for reducing crypto
overheads in FedOne which could lead to various
performance improvements in the underlying
code base. First thing is you could disable
a crypto if the server is local-only. DSA
signatures give you some scalability at a
fairly cheap cost. This would be if you could
get and use DSA certificates for assigning
usually the deltas because DSA is about 10
times faster to sign. Three times slower to
verify but 10 times faster to sign at about
a thousand signs and a thousand verifies per
second. And at least from my benchmarks in
applying [INDISTINCT] law, I would estimate
that would improve the FedOne throughput from
about a factor of five using one CPU core.
Other traces are more implementation complexity
to be RSA with Merkle trees or these implementation
terms' much more complicated splice signatures.
Now don't--you don't have to be as complicated
as--you can't verify them without actually
using the splices because the spliced signatures--the
splices may be used but they don't have to
be used. You could always verify issue message
one at a time, in which case, it's a little
more complex that doing--than doing Merkle
trees. So the code status I have here is the
underlying code for the cryptography building
on the prune trees and serializing them is
complete and unit tested. The queue for managing
the APIs--asynchronous APIs I described is
somewhat more immature and the spliced signatures--all
the bookkeeping to track all the splices is
the least matured code base. We don't need
to do--but that doesn't have to be--spliced
signatures can still be used without having
that code activated. Questions? Yes.
>> In your experiment, were you running all
this through FedOne?
>> CROSBY: No. I was hoping to but I didn't
understand the FedOne code base enough to
actually integrate in with the crypto back-ends.
>> So you're just generating the XMPP traffic?
>> CROSBY: I was actually running a separate
program. I basically generated a program that
would--I generally the queue--stuff which
operated those queuing the asynchronous API
we described. Then sent a traffic generator
which submitted messages to that, finding
the Google Wave trace data. So we submitted
information into the queue saying, "Message
arrived, message arrived." And then we requested,
okay, user just log-in now first on the following
messages.
>> Was your Merkle tree--like, so the Merkle
tree is just you every time you send a Merkle
tree it was with a proper trace area?
>> CROSBY: Yeah.
>> It was a list of hashes...
>> ...and a signature of the entire trading?
>> CROSBY: No.
>> And then what kind of classifications if
you saw that signature again for the group
hash or the hash which is part of the trade
[INDISTINCT].
>> CROSBY: Hold on. So what's the question?
>> I'm trying to figure out how it actually
be included in the [INDISTINCT] so if, let's
say, the--a wave of like one federating server
and the whole [INDISTINCT] server then does
each op individually say, "I'm sending you
this element in the tree. Also, here are a
bunch of hashes."
>> CROSBY: Well, no. Each op--I'm actually
presuming a semantics of I have the data bug--a
byte array coming in and byte array coming
out.
>> Yeah.
>> CROSBY: The outgoing byte array consists
of basically the green things you see--the
four green hashes along with using this current
FedOne certificate to sign the hash of the
root. So it consists of the current signature
size plus four hashes plus a few bites of
vertical buff above overhead.
>> Yup.
>> CROSBY: That's--each one is independent
and separately sets.
>> Okay. But does--but on the other side,
the server which we verify is, well--it'll
cache the hash every now and then. In that
way, it precedes another element which is
in that same tree again [INDISTINCT].
>> CROSBY: It could. However, in practice,
I expect trees would be relatively small.
For example, 20--might be as few as 20 elements
because if you're running an--RSA is the slowest
algorithm. If you--I mean, it could still
run in this code base right here about 80
times a second which means it's at 20 elements
per tree. You're talking about a throughput
of 1,600 messages per second which is five
times faster than the one CPU throughput of
FedOne in the benchmark that I did.
>> Yeah.
>> CROSBY: In which case, if you happen to
encounter two in the same tree, you could
apply the optimization and you could ask--if
you're Google Scale...
>> Yeah.
>> CROSBY: First of all, is it worthwhile
even to detect that duplication effort. If
we're not Google scaling, I mean, I think
your odds of even getting towards the same
tree is pretty low.
>> Yeah.
>> CROSBY: And if you're on Google's scale,
is it worthwhile detecting it?
>> Right. Yeah. Do you also encode the overhead
of waiting until you have that many messages
before you send any of them to the federation?
>> CROSBY: In practice--since the time to
actually build the tree is so small, in one
millisecond, I can build a tree of 20 nodes.
So I don't--RSA loop, it's 10 milliseconds
to do the signature, which you have to pay
no matter what. And then one millisecond lets
you add 20 things under the tree so getting
one millisecond under the latency in return
for up by about 18 times increase in the throughput.
>> Okay.
>> CROSBY: So you are adding us--you are adding
leads with such a small amount relative to
the signature size that it's--that optimization
is almost--in terms of latency, it's almost
free.
>> Yeah. Cool.
>> CROSBY: I do have latency graphs for the--all--half
of the figure. I don't have them in the presentation.
But generally speaking, up to 20 or 30,000
per second, latency is about--you give them
about two or three signatures.
>> Yeah.
>> CROSBY: So you're talking 30 milliseconds,
pretty much 90% of the time, less than 30
milliseconds.
>> Okay.
>> CROSBY: And with the DSA, less than 10
milliseconds...Yes?
>> You said that the problem is the remote
host offline [INDISTINCT]. What will you do
if it never comes back [INDISTINCT] resending
deltas and then even it never comes back so
you will never be able to complete all the
data just to verify it?
>> CROSBY: No, sorry, do you mean the case
of the spliced signature example? Or do you...?
>> Yes.
>> CROSBY: Okay. Then in this case right here,
what actually--a spliced signature, I think
it--oh, I'm sorry. I--If you remember the
Merkle I just had right there, a spliced signature
includes additional path, additional leaves,
so it's included as part of the signature
atomically. So a spliced signature right here,
this would include about a dozen or so more--10
to 20 more hashes than just a straight Merkle
tree signature would include and it can be
verified independently of any remote server.
So if you adjust these three blobs and no
other information whatsoever, I can do the
verification. This means includes additional
information and then makes it independent
of any future contact with the server. So
you have the public key to use to verify the
individual message and you have the auxiliary
information independent from the server to
link it with a prior message. And if it links
to a prior message that you don't have, well,
you just ignore it. Or if you--or if you don't--or
if, for example, the status message never
arrived at all; say, Bob--pretended B didn't
exist. Here I include C as a splice to B I
don't have; in which case, I have to verify
both A signature and C signature. And this
is actually--the hash is supposed to--splice
will be overhead that I paid but I get nothing
for it. However, in practice, you can generate--in
the case of Wave, you can generate useful
splices. If, for example, Alice is sending
three messages in the Wave, you can always
include a splice to the previous message that
Alice sent to the same Wave. That's an obviously
good thing to know that that means that their
readers can be able to verify all three messages.
And you--so you need to make sure the splice
has some minimal usefulness. If Alice is--if
Bob is willing to take--Bob's server is willing
to take the latency hits either voluntarily
or involuntarily through overload. In my example,
I overloaded very often in my trace simulation
and so what it does, Bob was forced to use
splices even though Bob wanted to verify--my
message immediately. So I had to verify the
public signature immediately; but I was on
overload, I wasn't able to keep up.
>> Great. Thank you [INDISTINCT].